as Robin so lovingly said my name is
Tages as pronounced like contagious I am
not contagious I don't have any corona
things or anything but I know I know
it's that I do work at G 2i g 2i is a
company that we have like an army of
react engineers and companies come to us
and say hey I need five engineers and
we're like we know just the people and
so we're really kind of matchmaking
developers to companies and I lead the
team that vets new applying engineers
but you know we're not here to talk
about that we're not here to talk about
me we are here to talk about
deconstructing react and before we get
into the talk this talk by the way is
very technical and we're not even gonna
be looking at slides you're gonna be
looking at code for the most part but
before we get into that I need to
clarify why why are we even doing the
react works react is good I use react
you probably use react everybody who's
recommendable wrote a book about react
so why and this this very small text is
the reason so people have been asking me
how do I learn things in case you don't
know I am NOT educated I have no degree
in computer science I am I didn't even I
barely went to school like in a school
year I'd attend like maybe nineteen days
I'm just completely uneducated but I did
take things apart when I was like six
seven years old we had a family computer
I would break that and my parents would
get mad at me but this is how I learned
right and so this is kind of what I do
with react as well I when I didn't
understand rxjs I just took it apart and
okay what is this observable thing what
is an observer how does it work and
similarly with react and so I think
there's a lot of value for us if we look
under the hood of react a little bit and
try to see how it works
that we can then take back to our
everyday jobs and use for example if I
was to ask you right now why are there
hooks
why are there rules of hooks why can I
not put a hook in it if how many of you
show me how many of you can tell me the
answer confidently yeah there's like
four people you're like half okay
three people three and a half people
examined my hope is after this talk
you'll kind of understand these things
go back to work and be like ah I can
write more fluent react applications
okay that's the hope so let's get to
work
that was literally all the slides except
there there's one more I need to give
you a disclaimer I I'm not part of the
react core team I do not work at
Facebook I do not make react I open the
pull request once and it was ignored so
this is just my playing and
experimenting and does not fully
represent react if you want that I'd
recommend you know Dan Abramov is around
not here but you know on the Twitter's
look there but for our sake let's get to
work and with that I'm gonna exit out a
keynote oh I have to accept something
okay cool cool cool cool cool cool good
alright so let's get to work I'm here in
the LAT is this is this sighs good
there's a lot of white but we'll see so
i'm i will make a folder and i'll call
it our react i'm seeing in there
typescript is my language of choice you
can choose whatever you want but I'd
really like typescript and I need
something to build it so I'll do parcel
two and this is what I needed Wi-Fi I
hope the Wi-Fi is good
if not I'll like do a dance or something
you don't want to see that believe me
alright good it's fine you know it feels
to me cuz I'm on stage it feels to me
like time is moving way faster than it
actually is
the previous speaker could probably
agree okay good it's done so we will
open I literally this is I just made
this folder so there's nothing here we
are starting from zero okay I'm gonna
yarn TSC in it so I'm gonna just start
up type scripts and so now I have this
TS config file up here and I'm just
gonna tell it let's make this nice and
big I'm gonna tell it we have some JSX
and it's react we're using and I'm going
to for this purpose turn off all the
strictness I don't I don't care don't do
this in your apps at work this is
exactly but we'll just turn that off for
now
I will create two files I need an
index.html of course that my web server
will serve and this will take an indexed
ESX so no magic and here I will do
indexed ESX so what we're going to look
at in this talk three things three react
fundamentals and what makes react work
number one the virtual Dom okay we've
heard this buzzword a lot virtual Dom
which will download what is it we're
gonna look at that number two we're
gonna look at hoax it's the new hotness
how do hooks work why do the rules apply
and number three concurrent mode which
isn't even released but we're gonna kind
of look at some specifically one
controversial decision that Facebook
made and we'll kind of dissect it and
talk about it so let's start with the
virtual Dom actually we need to start
one level even before let's start with
JSX
so I'm gonna go ahead and serve this app
I will do yarn parcel go away yarn
parcel index dot HTML and this is gonna
start up a little dev server looking Wow
one second welcome to 2020 and I'll open
this up and we have a blank page whoa
all right I'm gonna take this black page
put it here and we're gonna be spending
a lot of time side by side so I'm
loading index tsx let's also open the
console get some console action and make
that nice and big for you
okay so Const a equals div hello
you recognize this right this is this is
reactor JSX but I have an error reactor
is not defined wha
I didn't import react from react of
course but we're not gonna do that we're
gonna make react so I'll just do okay
Const react you know what controvert let
react that's right and I'm proud of it
okay so now react is defined it's an
object okay but now react dot create
element is not a function so so what
we're learning here is this thing calls
react not create element okay so okay
cool so now I just go ahead and create
element
expecting it to be a function so I'll
just do that okay no errors but also
nothing so what does this function what
is this thing well here's as far as
function expect let's see the arguments
that this function expect so I'm gonna
look at args here and I will console.log
what are you what are you oh look at
that there's three arguments to this
function div okay so I guess it passes
that null and hello and I'm seeing here
hello as children so what could the
second one be wow you guys are so and
girls are so smart welcome to
kindergarten react so we will give it a
class name BAM okay so we have the
second one it's props and so forth I've
created an element so what I need to do
is I'm just console logging it though so
I'm not really creating anything so if I
go ahead and let's add some stuff h1
hello person per parens and I will just
add some lorem ipsum nothing special
great okay just have some text and so
I'm calling create element a bunch of
times and that's what we see here and
this one here we see create element
called on the root div that's the only
div and there's two undifferenced like
some undefined stuff what's going on
turns out children's an array so we need
to actually return something we're just
console logging args now let's return
something and console.log that so create
element what does it do
I'm assuming it creates and returns an
element so const element is the future
so element is just gonna be an object
tag is tag is I'm just gonna change this
to actually tag props children children
is an array so I'm just gonna do that
and so tag props but I want all the
props and I also want props children to
contain the children okay
great and then of course I need to
return it but I want to also console.log
it return elements BAM
great it looks a little bit but we're
actually seeing here our first react
elements that that have been created I'm
not interested in the children I'm
interested in the route one the div so
what do we got give props class name
2020 children I have two children H one
and H one has children and so on so what
we're looking at here is a what what's
the structure called it's a tree it's a
tree what else is a tree the Dom is a
tree what we what we have here is the
virtual Dom the virtual Dom is just an
object is the object with children
there's no magic that's what it is and
so that's one third of our talk already
done it's just here you go let's thank
you so we have it's all good but it's in
console to the hug man like I'm not even
it's all on the screen so next step
let's put it on the screen but there's a
flaw here because if I make this a
little bit smaller what you see is this
isn't actually a react component what is
this
it's a react element it's not a string
but nice try it's a it's a react element
what do I need to do to make it a
component needs to be a function exactly
so this now it is a react component and
let's follow the convention is called
app does it still work though it doesn't
I have no console.log because this is a
function we need to account for this
case so if typeof tag equal equal equal
you know what we're breaking all the
rules today function I will call it with
props okay and that and I need to
actually return that sorry I need to
what that's right I'll get there
good so basically this is what they were
saying very good and so it works as
expected
no problem everything's fine but I need
to put on the screen and this is where
Part B of react comes in which is the
renderer
so what we've just done is implement
poor-man's react that that's all it is
but react is just a part of the puzzle
you need to have something that takes
your virtual Dom tree puts it somewhere
right react native does this for iOS
Android whatever react Dom does it for
the browser react native Dom does it
there's a lot of different there's react
ink that does this on the CLI just takes
the react tree puts it on there so we
need to create our render function so
let's just write the API first render
that into document dot query selector
app already render is not defined of
course import rendered no we're writing
this so I need to also have an app
element here so I'll just do this and
here's a here's a protip for you any
element in the Dom with an ID the ID is
also a global JavaScript variable so you
could do that if you really want to yeah
but let's let's just let's just be
purists about it I might want to get
kicked out of this meetup and never come
back ever again I don't never happen
haha okay so we need to define render so
Const render yeah okay we'll do Const
and I will take a react element and a
container okay and I will render it so
what is rendering mean in this case I'm
rendering to the Dom so I need to map
the virtual Dom element to the actual
Dom so I need to document create element
so that's what I'll do Const actual Dom
element element equals document dot
create element react element dot tag
because that's what we did up here when
we create the element it has a tag
property okay so work we're done we next
need to take the props apply them on the
actual Dom element and we need to take
the children nest that
all right so if react element dot props
if it even has props because it's
optional then we'll take the keys of
them dot keys react element props we
will filter them out for children we'll
deal with children separately so P is
not too many not children and then for
each of them we'll just apply them to
our new actual Dom element so we'll say
actual Dom element P equals react
element P that's pretty much it I need
to do the same thing for children so if
react element props dulled Rijn what do
I want to do for children Randi
recursively so I will call for each of
the children so react element dot props
for each child I will render but this
time the react element being rendered is
the child into what container this one
correct so there we go perfect
and then lastly what's the final step
append the root to the container so we
will container dot append child actual
Dom element now this might fail because
there's one case we have not yet
accounted for but let's see if this
works
yeah it doesn't it doesn't because
cannot read property children of
undefined we're not only dealing with
objects here if you look at this tree
these are not react elements they're
just strings do they have children
properties they don't they're string
primitives and so this thing can be
either a react element or a string or a
number this is why we need typescript so
if this actually that if type if string
or number includes type of this thing I
need to treat these differently so none
of this magic
here on a document dot create text node
coerce it to a string and put it in
there and I want to actually let's move
this a little bit that's fine and so
what I'll do here is container dot
append child and I'll just return I
won't do anything else so I don't know
what there we go it's working this we
have a render we have a render and this
this treat can be as deep as I want I
could even be like here let's just put
an input field in there for fun input
type is text placeholder equals name
okay cool
save that I have input ice holders on I
don't know what's happening it's I have
a what okay what's the air I mean ah
wait wait wait wait line 32 what's my
air
ah thanks who said that Chum you're in
you're the king crowd applauses - good
so it's working it's great everything's
super but our apps gotten a useless cuz
why it has no state it's just like okay
great you put stuff on there I could
write this in HTML faster than you tages
come on you're violating the code of
conduct by thinking that kick them out
anyway um so state we need state let's
add statement that was the virtual Dom
that was a renderer let's talk hooks
hooks are my jam
we need state so let's go here we're
changing absolutely nothing except we're
just being a little bit more verbose so
everything's gonna be fine I don't want
these warnings how do I like yes yes yes
filter no it's not filter that one no
warnings there we go
I should also turn off errors and then
my app would have nobody okay so cons
let's let's do name because I don't like
this person it's very impersonal right
so Const name set name use state no name
by default
I guess person why not and we'll go
ahead and interpolate here name with a
JSX expression and what I want to do is
value is name and on change II let's
just set name e dot target value now
something really interesting you need to
notice this is never gonna work why
because we're not the actual web
platform specification for inputs is
this okay it's not this this is react
this is web so we're gonna use the
platform good let's see what happens
oh no you state is not different of
course yes then for now we will write it
Const
use state so let's think about how it
works I have my initial state in the
argument and then I return what I
returned a tuple with the state and a
setter simple so initial State
and i so i'll just capture the initial
state so i actually we're going to
mutate that so state initial state and
then set state new state state equals
initial state kind of ah you can tell
i'm on the top of my game today and then
we'll return state and set state okay
looks okay not bad does it work
kind of good good does it update
oh no i am such a bad coder okay I quit
no just kidding okay so how do we make
this work well for one thing we need to
re-render right because when you update
state rerender so let's take our render
function and let's add a rerender
function to it so what we'll do is we'll
just copy this render and this is
poor-man's react okay there's not how
they actually do it but let's just do
that again what what oh arrow right okay
good but let's actually just try that
and then we'll call rerender when we
call set state so this is not just a
reassignment but we will also rerender
is this gonna work but why not what's
what's wrong state order so now but
check this out
oh we have a pen child okay so with
rerender will clear well clear the first
child will clear the root and we add the
root whatever and this actually works
but what's going on here okay so no
that's not true what's what's happening
is we can let's use console.log to debug
console log okay use state called with
initial state and in set state console
log set state call with
new state all right let's see what's
happening you stayed called it person
good it mounted change person to Robin
it is changing it so we're setting the
state but immediately rebounding with
the initial state you don't see it so
we're starting to understand now how
hooks work how do we fix this we use
something that is very popular in
JavaScript
exactly yeah look that that is what
closure exactly so if you've ever done a
JavaScript interview and somebody has
asked you about closure and prototype
inheritance this is a prime example
react hooks works with closure and
closure for those of you if you aren't
informed is it's it's when a functions
scope encloses over a inside function
scope so we're gonna assume that all of
this this actually is happening inside a
module or a function or a closure every
JavaScript module is a closure okay so
this file is no exception
so we will who said global state you're
right but closure state so it's not on
window it's inside this module we will
have state B this and we what we need
here is some type of cursor because we
have multiple moving parts of state you
know how many times have you seen an app
with just one state name right in fact
let's add this example so we go to our
JSX tree and we'll add two pieces of
state okay the count is and this is just
a classic example and we'll add some
buttons not blur buttons on click and
we'll set count to count plus one plus
button and count minus one and of course
we need to call count set count use
state zero alright so this is not gonna
do anything because it's the same
problem but now we have two moving parts
of state cool so we'll have our state in
a store in a you
versal kind of outside scope was a const
States or yeah we can say states equals
this and we need something to point to
which state am I talking to right now
and so we'll just call it let State
cursor equals zero so every time we call
you state it's going to set a state in
this array at index zero at index one at
index 2 and so on and these are the
moving parts of our app so if you think
with me when we call this it's going to
set index 0 to person when we call this
it's going to set index 1 to our count
which is 0 and so forth but we need to
work with this so let's yeah we don't
need the console logs anymore we will
freeze the state cursor here so we'll
say Const frozen cursor ah equals state
cursor and what we want to do is just
only work with that in here this is
where closure comes in so we'll say
state we don't even need that actually
so will reassign States at the frozen
cursor okay and we'll return this one
from the outer scope good we just need
to do one more thing and that is
increment the cursor to the next one so
when you state finishes it says okay I'm
done next piece of state so what we'll
do is plus plus exactly that's why it's
would let two so state cursor plus plus
does this work cannot report what what
did I do wrong
I miss typescript
okay oh so it doesn't like this I think
it was cashed parcel has a really nasty
cache console.log that's it called it
everything oh but I removed these just a
second all right so we have this frozen
cursor is the state cursor super and we
will just return States at we need to
sorry we need to also set the initial
one frozen cursor equals the initial
state perfect and then we will yeah and
then we will reassign it here in set
state and we will render return that
good
yeah thanks that's a good that's really
important one state cursor plus plus
break everything come on okay good it
doesn't I think it was just the cash
what's go away okay super so now
everything's fine does it work it still
doesn't work and that's because on
render we need to reset the cursor so
when we render all the the cursors go to
zero we call that state index 0 in the
x1 index to everything set and we reset
it so let's go back to that rerender
here here and we will state cursor is
back to 0 this in theory should work but
i okay why doesn't so and and this is
where I don't know why I tried lets
console.log states
yeah totally works ah what do you see
what's happening we're resetting it I
call what again that's right so we need
to read the it's not always the initial
state good good call
so instead of initial state it's either
this one if it exists or the initial
state perfect and now everything is fine
perfect there we go and so from this you
can see so if we on every time we mutate
state let's just console.log the global
state to see what's going on and so you
can kind of see them updating here in
real time and this is kind of the index
that react has the this is a little bit
behind because the way input works but
this is kind of how it works
and so if you have you state called a
hundred times you just have an array
with a lot of indices but because of
this now can you kind of see why the
rules of hooks applies what's one of the
rules of hooks can't no hooks and
conditionals you have to love them
unconditionally
thanks Ryan Florence so if let's
actually just declare these variables
here for the sake of demonstration
nothing's nothing don't do this in
production at all but we let these be
things zero and a function that does
absolutely nothing and instead of Const
we'll just reassign them here and we'll
say if I don't know like 5050
math.random greater than point five then
we'll set this if not we won't write and
watch our app be really weird okay hmm
nothing's happening but let me change
this and so sometimes it works some and
this is because on every render things
either this count either works or
doesn't so it's just a really confusing
our luck is really not yeah so if your
app doesn't expect the way you should
this is
I shouldn't said counted yeah yeah it's
just a look at this it's just really
strange well where does 380 even come
from its octave okay Wow welcome but now
it's zero but at some point it's this
and so we it's completely unpredictable
and this is why we look at this this is
why we have the rules
Hookes thankfully react will throw ho if
you do that so you're good but that
should help you understand it alright
we're done with two thirds how are we
doing on time do we have time to go
concurrent or okay cool it's just Lego
or whatever
awesome awesome alright we're gonna talk
concurrent mode and then we will you
know eat pizza do whatever we do what a
lightning talks like save for those they
are amazing
cool concurrent mode so for those of you
who haven't heard of concurrent mode it
is async rendering it's the way react is
able to literally suspend it stops
rendering waits for some side data to
come in from somewhere and then
continues the react team came under a
lot of fire for the way they implemented
it because they people would say they
abuse the JavaScript specification by
throwing not errors but promises and
personally me I don't think that's
abusing the language I think it's
creatively using the light nor does it
say you can't throw whatever you want I
could throw the dice in JavaScript if
you manage to do that I could do
whatever I want so let's look at how
that works so let's assume let's go to
my function where's my phone well this
app app is my component all right and I
want to do something asynchronous here
Const
I'm gonna use the classic example you
can put our dog photo URL and how fetch
from my favorite API breeds and it's
scary that I know that by heart
see here lies their response to chase on
and then i ieave enou the payload so the
payload payload message okay great what
do you want now cannot find name payload
do do define oh it's a function got it
you see how I called it dude all right
cool everything's good it's like it's
for Oh foreign which means did I get it
wrong yes it's five it's I think it's
run its image random yeah that's the one
wait yeah I always swap them man
alright works image random perfect good
all right so I'm fetching something but
nothing's happening and if I go down
here and I try to let's put it here
let's do this and see what I see oh look
there's nothing oh I have a huge error
cannot read probably children if
undefined oh my goodness what's
happening why did someone tell me why
it's a promise
it hasn't resolved it says hey I'm gonna
go fetch data and come back whatever but
not now
and we don't if you look here we're not
actually doing anything with promises so
good luck
so we need some way to wrap this promise
and know when it's ready and this is the
first part of suspense for data fetching
in concurrent mode react expose is a
primitive called create a resource and
it's a function that just wraps your
promise it's kind of all it does and the
second argument is some type of key a
unique key a name so we'll call this dog
photo okay now the air is Korean
resources we were getting a lot of not
defines but we define them so it's all
good
Const create resource what do I want to
do with this
it gets to things it gets a promise and
the key okay so what I want to do with
this is I want to check has this promise
been resolved is the data ready to be
shown or is it not yet ready and then
make a decision so to know if the data
is ready or not I need some type of
centralized cache again closure not
global
so Const promise cache cache new and
it's just a map nothing special
okay and what we'll do is we'll check if
promise cache
it has our key and we'll just return it
promise cache get keep them if it
doesn't though what do we do we need
something so we need some way from as
deep as we are in the tree we need some
way to respond to this so we can't just
do like one level up as you know with
react apps the component trees are deep
super deep
if you've inspected you would have divot
if div div right and so we need
something to respond to that from the
top now this is how a try-catch works
you could throw an error anywhere and
catch anywhere and it just knows this
emulates a functional programming
paradigm called algebraic effects a way
to a way to respond to things
deep inside globally and so we're gonna
use try catch for that to catch
something though we need to what I need
to do that and we will throw the promise
and its cache key and so now let's save
this we have an uncaught dog photo the
next logical step is to catch it
where do we where do we catch it though
this is a question you see where we're
throwing in the app function where does
the app function get called no wrong
answer but good try it gets called and
create element all the way at the
beginning of the talk if you weren't
paying attention
booooo-whoo now but it get this is where
it gets called so we need to try catch
this thing so let's try to return that
sure but we'll catch the promise cache
key and what do we want to do with this
we wonder we need to show something the
user needs to see something so right off
the bat without even thinking I'm going
to return let's just do a return a div
and props children I am loading and you
know what I'll return in h1 because I
want to shout it doesn't work it doesn't
work why props as no children is what
props are children not for each oh it
means to be an array typescript I you
okay
there we go I'm loading we need to wait
for loading to finish and then rerender
so promised dot ten whenever it finishes
data we get data some data we don't know
what it is
and what we're gonna do is set it in the
promise cache dot set key to data and I
will re render and so now promise dot
then is not a function
I might you've been throwing a promise
what am i throwing ah yeah you're right
you're right I'm not calling it correct
correct I need to call it let's go here
and promise is thing that returns so I
laid me there
you're right whoever said that I love
you thank you okay good now we have
perfect we have the URL but we're not
showing it and so just for to close us
out let's image this thing alt equals
good boy ye and just like that we've
implemented concurrent mode it waits
thank you and so with that we just
implemented poor-man's react and we
implemented three pillars on which
poor-man's react works let's just
quickly talk some takeaways you see
because this is this is literally
poor-man's react okay it's not it
doesn't even come close I mean there's
the whole topic of the reconciler bread
first algorithm that searches and
detects changes and re-renders
accordingly we didn't even touch that
but that's not the purpose the purpose
was to learn and I mean this is a risky
move but how many of you learned
something new about react oh that's the
entire room okay I've done my job
good and so let's just quickly talk some
takeaways number one building is
learning I have so many conversations
with people say I should I build this
thing I mean I don't nobody uses
nobody's gonna use my poor man's react
okay I just built it in front of me
nobody's gonna use it but I don't care I
learned a ton you learned a ton
building this together building is there
if nobody uses it that's fine it doesn't
matter I hope you get your validation
from a better place number two time is
never wasted I spent a lot of time kind
of figuring this stuff out and a lot of
people say okay but what you have to
show for it well I understand react
better but does that really get me
richer probably not does it does it help
my family and it doesn't but I would
still say this time wasn't wasted
because I've learned some stuff and so
the focus here is learning and lastly
this all started when I was just like
man am I can I think do I qualify to be
an engineer at Facebook do I do I do I
think like an Abramov you know what I do
I do i am i yeah and so you know and I
just
it started with wonder how does react
actually I've tried to read the react
source code I don't get it there's like
secret Facebook internals don't use or
you'll be fired or whatever like I don't
I don't know um but I was wondering and
from wonder came this I'd encourage you
all so first speaker was wondering about
migration how is this working and the
wonder led to amazing products and so
I'd encourage you with that wake up
wander doesn't matter if nobody uses it
you're not gonna waste your time is
gonna be meaningful with that thank you
very very much
[Applause]